[Music]
oh my far right is counselor ring fool
and my wife is cheating and on my left
is the legal advisor email address
please
first of all the emergency evacuation
center council chamber should we be
going
please leave a message I'm single now so
this wouldn't be a public car park at
the side of the city sweet
you don't delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
accessibility notes will give permission
to do so by the council start please
know that this meeting is all here
all these could everybody please set up
their telephones the purpose of this
series consider an application for
example
we hold on the thirty-first of money at
the rich door well 3-1 I Street railings
6 so this is my African again we'll see
you will have an opportunity to speak
and ask questions please don't speak
when it is your turn please film the
counsel was he also introduced himself
you're going am finite-state green out
on the bus sitting opposite of russian
issue thank you sir
cook the applicant and that wall yet
because have the retention to introduce
himself or 10g proposed support any
witnesses you not see the other adult
thank you as this is an application for
temporary event Mosley's rather than
their license only interesting part is
permitted to make the upset
representations are the police and the
Environmental Health Department of the
council in the role as responsible
authorities the Environmental Health
Department sophistical injection does
with possible Authority wish to speak
have all parties received agenda and
reporters face hearing okay follow me
questions at this stage the hearing will
follow the procedures set out on pages
3.1 3.3 with agenda
150 minutes nobody respond 40% their
submissions 15 minutes per music that
they could present their submissions all
parties that make submissions of the
hearing also people two minutes at the
end of the hearing to make a closing
statement opinion summary do the the
application from the license officer I
suppose will be asked now to introduce
application and present the report okay
good boy this reports introduces an
application for a temporary event ladies
made under Section 100 of the license an
extra 2003 during the consultation
period an objection was received
responding funds will help with your
garden that findability
the application must be determined at
the conclusion of the hearing at least
24 hours before the beginning of the
event in accordance with paragraph 26
one of the licensing acts 2003 hearing
regulations
2005 and section 105 propofol of the
licensing acts treatment group on the
template to pay 2018 HMP event notice
was received from mr. Lyon velocity in
relation to an application for the Rick
Dore public house for Thursday the 31st
of May 2018 and a copy is part of
attendees a
that patient is to extend their
permitted time under their license for
the sale of alcohol and regulated
entertainment the license for activities
the subjects of an application are the
seller Banco and reverses 10
entertainments the maximum number of
people attending the event is to be 499
the premises already holds a premises
license allowing the sale of alcohol on
Sundays to Thursdays between 10:00 and
midnight Friday between 10:00 a.m. and
1:00 a.m. the following morning and
Saturday between 8:00 a.m. and 1:00
o'clock the following morning regulated
entertainment is permitted on Sundays -
Thursday from 8:00 in the morning until
half past midnight the following day and
on Friday and Saturdays from 8 in the
morning until 1:30 before tonight the
application relates to many things she
falls on a Thursday requesting the the
sale of alcohol and regulates
entertainments to be permitted to talk 1
in the morning on Thursday the 31st the
application was sent to us its police
environmental health with a deadline of
reporting to point 2018 representing an
objection by Jesus has been received
from Thomas Cup on the grounds that the
use of premises in accordance with the
temporary event notice was undermined
the objection objective of the
Prevention of public nuisance under the
Act Appendix C consists of dictionaries
for all parties involved for being
served with the relevant matrices and
documentation required by paragraphs 4
at 6 & 7 of the licensing X 2003
appearance regulations 2005 the matrices
and documentation included an
explanation of the rights of persons to
attempt a hearing and to be
representatives to give evidence and
call witnesses the consequences of
attending the procedure to be followed
by a hearing and for applicants only a
copy of all Grossman representations
mate paragraph 18 ninth of the
regulations required that parties
notified the licensing authority no
later than two working days before the
hearing of those matters mentioned in
paragraph 3.5 above a pro forma and
prepaid envelopes was included us for
this purpose with the Mexican
documentation mentioned in paragraph
frequent-flyer above the legal grips
implications the provisions of the
licensing has 2003 the Licensing Act
2003 here is regulations 2005 guidance
under section 182 of the licensing enter
2003 and the statement of licensing
policy approved by full counsel for the
period of the 31st of January 2016 to
the 31st of January 2010 221 needs to be
considered by members in determining the
issue the licensing authority must serve
any notices required under section 105
section 3 of the Licensing Act 2003 at
least 24 hours before the beginning of
the year penance options the following
options were available to the members to
determine that the event would undermine
their licensing objective of the
Prevention of public nuisance and serve
a counter notice stating the reasons for
the decision or to allow the licensing
activities to go ahead as stated in
damages the recommendation it is
requested subcommittee resolves in the
determinant of this application having
considered all representations
I have a couple of questions for you if
that's okay
yeah mostly should this be granted this
is extension really still premises
license conditions apply you can as a
committee you can apply the existing
premises lots of conditions on to accept
pre-event notice you cannot add any
further conditions for pass the premises
passed on to the notice also can all
some of the conditions such as
specifically added to the type so that
you also know that couldn't if it's a
condition on their practice if license
they don't say then yes that can be
included so all the existing conditions
can be used as positive information
yeah just so terrified responsible for G
submission you have 15 days more money
Sean Sheldon and environmental health
make the objection on the following
grounds and we are we received a common
complaint inspected noise emanating from
also following that investigation our
records indicate and that the current
license conditions on pavement and in
states of condition 19 and the original
requirement from us needs have been
useful data premises and this has been
fulfilled also respective condition is
there in the research premises
and she waits and appendixes down the
railway station in the area
could you just advise us what conditions
have not been applied condition of 19
and providing properly conditionalities
providing properly use and noise
limiters on amplification equipment to
control the level of noise produced by
music on the premises so as not to be a
nuisance to nearby properties or states
within two months of the quantify things
the apprehension creates a noise
management plan to be submitted and
agreed in writing the council's
environments at everything and noise
management plan will be implemented
prior to the opening of Romania remain
in effect for as long as the license
remaining
there's something you did to it it
really loves TV and the physician 26 at
the time I found application noise
management plan example with spikes and
to the place holder as an example and we
believe will be and the environment to
have a gypsy to investigate such reasons
noise being one of those and so
complained that we were state of
although it is it's substantially to get
there is an allegation that the noise
and that person's been significantly in
interfering with the enjoyment of their
quality is emanating from thank you very
much for that thank you
like to now us we have to come to make
your submission and then we can ask you
some questions offers okay
so most of our just heard will highlight
are chosen to come here today
there's any operation that's run by
myself
he's run professionally nothing goes
unnoticed I come here today because
there's two conditions that haven't been
met and that is a noise Action Plan and
the use of amplify that application
limiter device on the sound system when
the red door was set up myself and my
full measure there's not with us anymore
need a noise action plan we submitted
that and it's one of the hit mightily on
it because we've never done an action
plan before and we did receive a female
bank focus on Annie I know some changed
around not dealing with the same people
in water and we need to resubmit one and
I know that we submitted the noise
action claim because along it that I
remember which I said to Jane [ __ ] last
week I suppose was he a pink form and
she'd know it would've been a white one
and the pink form is actually a falling
that we need to run the sound food under
food hygiene I know that those both
forms of st. in if we had there seven
forms in the red dog would have been
training which is
the four years today so there must have
been a form in place if the council or
the the authority that looks the
environments will saw the things they
would have noticed system that would
have been lost our licensure that
solidly I know that for a fact
the second thing is the limiter we
discussed this we only have a domestic
source and system and a limiter could
not be fitted to the earthly boss so one
of the conditions was to have a
recording of investable readings on any
night where there's going to be about
that defied music and that's a form
every form that we have but it's applied
to our spotted license and quality gets
redone without standards something a bit
more modern and practical which is
basically like that right I'm there I'm
heading very basic but effective and one
of those forms is everything a license
in shape that the managers do on a
Chinese night and one of those there is
a nice mint and check and we go the
decibel reader during the busy is fun
the breather premises and we take our
best film briefings and they get 90 that
now kept in a park tough but when we
have a license in check which could be
at any rent and time unknown to us for
the police that have a look at when they
turn up and all the time we've been
trading
we've never had any issues at all
because their father has been spot on
deities when he needs to be so I've
redone another noise management plan for
the licensing side of things for
environmental which I can have a copy of
today which is more than adequate
everything is perfect on there the only
thing we've been doing from day one so
the other thing is there are two things
that now covers so they're saying that
we're not compliant our license will
guess we are there are two things of
rereads
done now the accommodation in that
facility there is nothing the only
reading further there are some flats
which on to the left-hand side of the
road or in built last year which do not
go over the top of our building
the labels haven't allowed the obviously
student converted into little places
because of the noise from our place or
whatever comes in that's a bother felony
issues so they are better way to not
cause any trouble the only parentheses
where people which supras off which
might be effective policies the police
station which is behind which is why I
understand is not used anymore
those parentheses are not occupied and I
believe that is what the light from
reported associate suggested here is
that that's a block this is fairly late
now no one uses that so there's no part
there that ought to be made and that's
what that was founded there's not much
more I can do we've done everything
we've asked and everything he's a bus
and this is the only representation
replanting three half four years of
mulch or multiple North actually take
the bait notice that we put in and
they've all been approved the only thing
I can and I'm not sure if I'm allowed to
know is who would have put this in blank
in because I don't think it's a genuine
one the red balls are very successful
business if dominated every single think
you've been in rightly because of the
type of clientele it attracts high in
customers add those respectful people
not you typical drink up it just goes
out to get wasting that also that's not
what the grateful client tells about I
can only assume it's someone being the
site businesses us similar tactics have
been knighted in the past where do
anything to see us operate or apply
online for example to try and cause
disruption all the lights and IP is a
gen and blame from the puppet as if it
is I need to know about it because maybe
they're saying that we can visit
accompany to resolve something people if
I don't know the door opened time fit
and all this point out as that person
was on their back anyway I don't know
but if it kept quiet
we can't do anything about it so if that
could be a good thing to do that we much
appreciate I thank you that respect
that's not for us
besides I'm not very little lieutenant
okay questions for you what was the
purpose of the extension we have a very
popular act called out of hat it's a
gentleman that doing all sorts of
hardstyle songs and is a very
entertaining they do a lot of ratings
and that sort of thing and we are asking
what we always do when our power plant
the right door is for an extra hour on
the Thursday and we've always done at
the Thursday and then have any issues
and that's the reason why we put a tent
event just for a niche ceramic because
it's usually all be because it's a
halftone all the mostly schoolteachers
is it about the next day they will come
and they've been spotted ease most
people in like teaching that there was
not so many other amenities it would
have been a few weeks ago was our last
one well it would be last month I think
it was a bang quality last month so we
issued Monday police thank you
I'm gonna actually have increased door
supervision on that Lance
so we don't actually without a risk
assessment we don't actually require
door staff on that night because it's
not particularly a busy night as I say
the clientele that go to a venue on a
Thursday and on finding taxis and peak
periods
obviously I'm there are lots of
conditions we have to have on a Friday
and Saturday night or Thursday night
there's no need for it it's too much of
a nice outdoor environment it's it's far
from my club where do you think like
they Sodor stuff whatever we do I need
temporary bed notice where doors are not
requires usually oh and find exactly
when you do that door itself their job
is to monitor the customers going in and
out and they do do what they're told to
do and that's obviously what a licensing
officers to do is reminding to the
peacefully limit the numbers that are on
the outside area so it's not too much of
a populate they're like too many people
at one point but ever seen or ever go up
the roads of our brand name is that we
always get h2so4 and one of those
interests off is to constantly keep an
eye on and what about conditions and
this is evidence but it doesn't actually
get done it's at past nine o'clock we're
not allowed any drinking outside the
venue on any training now past month in
evening and midweek not an issue because
we're not busy enough the names of staff
within the bark and keeping on there but
during busier times I am Friday Saturday
night the security come in at 8:00 off
now
to keep an eye on that fire now for so
there's no glass space was a guy outside
because we know that we will lose our
life in a straight way or go on to
review if there's glass vessels out
there so we have met the personal and
that specifically is keeping an eye on
that font area to restrict velocities
going out there so that's how we keep an
eye and the customers going in and out
obviously make sure that we're not
causing nuisance anything that's what
happens sorry I asked them if you can I
thought yeah
[Music]
we have over 30 people that work at the
red door and on a busy night we have a
minimum of non-stop fun when I say this
one staff is one personalities to keep
it on the glasses I think I not go work
to give us a team there is no assurance
of because we wouldn't allow it
the only time that we do outdoor
security is if we know for example we
would have a certain thing which would
bring a certain crowd of people that
could potentially cause trouble when
there's an event such as I've had
there is no trouble and it's a fact
because the topic line so they bring I
don't like morons
they've ankle trouble I don't do
anything like that that's why we only
entertain good acts and if we needed
security we'll provide it but on the
night on a Thursday night which is a
quiet night it's not needed at all
so it's a quite night when you meet the
extension yes we meet
ideally I'd lead a life because the set
that we pay I've had to do is done in
intervals and obviously if we're paying
for that full set we want that to run
and I'll see if the same for our
customers as well I what's happening the
same experience they used to with our
pipeline and it runs all the way through
they do different things they ask about
the knife then I end it in a certain way
what we don't want to do easily sort of
cut part the hell
and obviously that does make a big
difference but - don't you view it stall
for like half 12 to 1 it comes quite bad
it's not blooming all the way to the end
it's not like
customer why when were Thursday why not
do it on the nights that you already
have the they don't mean we already have
our busy part nights obviously within
the drinking industry visit I saw you
fighting Saturday nights so you know me
other night we've really do any sort of
entertainment which is usually onion 1/2
tone which is a 3/4 pound a year which
is Liza Thursday and any time do it it's
a nice place to have a lot of acting we
can't do live acts on a Friday or
Saturday because we have our DJ's on the
neckline as purely just for that reason
so has a significance to this yeah
that's because it's when we should break
up its majority of people break up their
kids we attract a lot of people have
been that sector that come out on that
Thursday night so they're not gonna cook
what appointed something sought to break
up there's a bit of times I'm not sure
the Internet of it
some it works on it some do break up on
the Friday right
majority P but some schools phone how
many customers are you expecting that
that well we can get anything it all
depends a last one was a particularly
busy one it will depends on what while
it falls on if there's an it before
though is definitely a die off if it's
like a good friday or sake and that is
usually a busy night for us but because
I believe these Fridays and any sort of
a public holiday it's not going to be
ugly that busy I can assure you to
expect and we probably expect somewhere
in regional probably about 60 to 80
before the known I suppose I belong here
also
oh geez here okay have you had any
previous complaints regarding I could go
stop during which not so have you got
issues in relation to what means wait
during the opiate do you have everything
have time would you expect to that to
reduce not only how about yeah and lost
in objectives is that we have a half a
drink cuts on ice they thought that
would remain ended
yeah yeah if you'll be all be getting
immunizations off now it's not saying
about certain ease
you have a skillet no Helen hours reach
are for example and regulates
entertainment can run all to a zero zero
and three hundred so it is only a half
an hour for the music side of things
which is which is an experiencer trait
or 12:30 with music and obviously
relative to one where is our alcohol
sales are for four o'clock cutoff a
concert pulsate
so we've the temporary bit notice it
takes to one o'clock so that gains an
hour for us but the actual issue with
the music is only half the original so
but you would still be something out
until one o'clock so that's great it
cost either scope know if runs up to 100
we do we we cut down these sales so what
we do is is try and get well we don't
when this is fast at staying on too late
and we turn the music down at us down
and in the sales start cutting them and
anchors out that drinking time and by
that time they're out on time we don't
want people past one o'clock for example
so for example if I a Saturday night all
the lights come on twenty years before
and until the lights come on or that and
use it goes down so by that time people
naturally feel right at the time to go
now
they dance for another half an hour
drinking and while acts fine they're
reading the premises where they
shouldn't be so that's why we have that
sort of animal do you have a problem
with people saying it helps life
this isn't working so she'll so yeah
timings what time are they work you two
what time will they be finishing well if
we get everything notice then it will be
so we'll finish it one and that's great
to hear
and so they finished one you're serving
drinks at one restaurant
and you want everyone out of one yeah
that's the same they turn the music down
it all goes that actually finished
around about twelve twelve just ask you
what time to actually finish their act
they finish their x-men about twelve
half twelve and then they just put
background music on my speaker system
and that is it and he's grouchy people
go they don't they are poor it's a lot
of dancing around that goes on so they
do have quite a lot of breaks and they
don't answer like threw the knife in
like four hours they start I haven't got
away fruit number one they do little sex
in there and in the last set is just
basically they go out and talk to the
customers try and get me business and
it's just literally background music
playing so you're expecting from one
boxes on the screen there yeah I'm
actually have a dream for five to one
and what's your bowl you can have a
great yeah all these people have died
Rancic a new business
background music and then at one o'clock
when your star course ID you've gotta
leave so I can walk up with this drink
in my management office so you're
expecting some apology not
control that they want to do that's
their option but as well one o'clock out
to as close we're not so fast that
that's see no no glasses at absolute the
venue we time with everybody else the
operation to the size of any other
drinking establishment and we have more
conditions on our license than any venue
in this town and we abide by them
extremely so there's no actual picking
up time messes up Chester yeah one
o'clock they're leavin at while and the
music's only available to one but it
also know people defense when they are
to every event notice if these grantees
on that for example depends what how we
get to if the untap apply until one yeah
and so you're great still one yeah and
everyone's out of one but our opening
hours are two or 1:30 in the morning
today is their hot that drink up we have
free is in email
you know I lost it we have freed it's
finally there's three different times we
have to look at it so we are that's
positive one in the morning so for
example at the old saying license is on
a fiber Saturday we can serve that
helpful one o'clock so half our drinking
times he's up to 130 and that is when
everyone has to be a better person
okay so on Thursday if we're asking for
an extra hour with basically getting out
Friday Saturday that effectively so one
yeah because it got off and so hot 130
there's there else it's basically if
either Saturday night repeated on the
Thursday that's all we're asking for
that's all better many people be
important that because we were in
monitoring people going outside there's
one which she's been is allocated purely
to front obviously this if it were not
that busy
and I even clubbed together but we have
a 14 Jerusalem inspectors said okay what
happens if you lose you expected would
you have facilities but having somebody
else in everyone but notice that person
a monetary they're allocated off while
supervisor that as they arrived in the
business and off our he's collecting
glasses making sure that the customer to
see if there's anything up like same
service things like that but it forms
always especially security not their
international no glasses got the fun
because also has to be a condition of
ours
are you satisfied
would you like to see the little pencil
gentlemen and they would like to see the
noise management plan and they
definitely gave that condition number 19
still have something that in regards of
noisy mr. premises
I appreciate this lasse has specified
that the system he currently has in
place doesn't is not compatible with the
noise meter but they were part of the
original conditions and this
consideration they should have taken
prior to purchase of the system they
currently have in place already include
the condition that mr. monatti is
referring to there is no specification
to and denote the decibel levels and
because we're such a nuisance and if
it's having a significant enjoyment with
some of these properties I've got matter
what they've always been the core needs
it's about how it affects enjoyment the
third property so it was requirement you
know clean levels and death bells what
we require is that an assessment is made
and to ensure that the noise from the
pros
affecting or even audible at boundaries
and every official premises thank you
well what one objective now when there
have been recent applications and there
have been previous attendees
applications that have been granted and
but we hadn't received noise complaints
at that stage we do have a covered most
of the complaint that we are coming
investigating which prompted us to look
because pops that complaint it was
illegal to realize that the noise was
being heard at residential premises so
it wanted us to look at the license
conditions on this day of which we have
no records in my positive making out
with vegetation conditions because it's
unclear how many noise complaints have
you know it's just in the last week so
and that was received a tenth of night
so yep according to the make a temporary
bed notification itself
could you confirm that the licensing
agreement is if Berg was to extend the
distance to 1 p.m. that they are to
continue to 130 for the drinking up to
America
I'm very under the legislation there is
nothing around loading times so all we
can license is the activity which is the
consumption of the alcohol and the
regulation statement it has there are
conditions in there around picking up
times and background noises has to be
reduced so effectively the Sal about
powers up to 1 o'clock
it doesn't actually stipulate the time
so they can still remain like the
accountability still come on trading but
further sort of the 1380
that's what he's suddenly agreed to just
wanted I'm not supposed to ask questions
but it might guide you a little bit was
to actually just double-check around to
the times of the stopping of the alcohol
and to stopping their API sustainment
itself and at the same time that
actually sometimes can be quite
problematic so is this going to be
you're going to stop that before so the
regulator's payment or is it literally
going to be shut off lights up everyone
sort of yeah it's really just as a
family to sort of get limited Gardens
really as to how it's going to be run
under day because that's what's gonna
determine how our white paper wake up
unusually very much could you clarify
that
yes sure it's the same for any night
that we had bought musical amplified
music this Alabama House coffee sauce at
one o'clock
because also has the long lasting
conditions and then obviously we have
two off one and that's going to say that
150 and Levi's come on and it's
obviously the music to tone down and
then you have a gradual transition rice
half past neck and go together
exactly how to do it it's not what
you're asking for on this occupation to
do one yeah it's an extra wrap mode
we've got three sets of hours to work
from here beside the closing time series
one of those clothes with bch around on
an existing I break the case and weekend
hours to Thursday or something
depressions you roast until one o'clock
is that correct
not 1:30
well does it maybe we can yell now sound
okay so it's just to clarify that the
red lights attainment is it 1:30 not
wake up yeah yeah that's very different
from the application has come in yeah
sneaky so the application states that
carrying on on Russell activity or if
they need to
you have just followed lirikh lirikh the
box this is on a five the center box and
has its feinex which says please take
the times during the advantage we've
replaced study unlawful activities
guidance notes nine should actually say
box over town this is just above zero
personal license holders which is person
is some of alcohols is correct
we have some closing statements there
would anybody like to close the
statement have two minutes
well thank you very much for that the
threesome intelligence application we
have heard evidence from environmental
health and boys complaint has been
received recently although this is
currently under investigation and it has
not been determined
furthermore conditions of the existing
premises license relating to the
management all floors of the premises
have not been complied with specifically
conditions 19 and 26 of these issues
further consultation the premises
license has been held for four years we
know that the applicant has provided the
noise management plan to environmental
health today we take into account the
lack of previous complaints however
there is an active investigation into a
recent complaint and it is a community
to promote the licensing objective of
the prevention of public nuisance
metaphorically it considers the
appropriate to allow the application
subject to the full set of existing
conditions on premises license being
applied to the ten for the avoidance of
doubt this includes position 19 and 26
which must be complied with in fall by
May 31st 2018
this concludes the hearing thank you all
for attending